right how you feeling oops first day of
the financial freedom challenge
so the plan is we're going to go get a
rent to rent
yes i think we should go for two rental
rents yeah i think we're not coming back
to this house
you won't be back to this house until we
have the key store rent to rent bro
that's the plan
that's gonna be amazing rent to rent
number one let's go manchester we're
coming for you
so we're in manchester today and we're
gonna try and bag ourselves at least
a couple of rent to rent deals how are
you feeling
feel confident if you're nervous or not
at all it's tightly ready
um don't get wrong there's a bit of
nerves there but i'm not going to play
on that
feeling i'm just going to go with the
conference yeah that's the best way to
be
yeah head in the sand to the nose feel
the fear and do it anyway exactly
[Music]
so you've had one call and had one
appointment
and both of them have gone terribly
just not starting very strong is it so
it looks like we've been chewed up and
spat out from the
center of manchester i thought
manchester was gonna be great because
i've heard really good things about it
my mom was born in manchester
lawton knows the area well i know
property well but the problem is
i don't know manchester at all he's not
done any deals in manchester before
i don't know where to start to be honest
so i think this could be a little bit
harder than we bargained for landlords
giving them
three years yeah do you guys do the
lettings as well for it
uh yeah we do but the landlord
yeah did you get two foot out yep on to
the next one
what it is is actually i'm looking for
long-term corporate let's
right yeah we don't really do that you
don't know the manchester agents don't
like rent until rent
not gonna lie it's hard here these
agents are
not having it i just don't need to get
some viewings
so bridgeford's no good homes for you no
good
let's try the next place
hey how's it going we've been
recommending actually to speak to you
from
um we've got a company where we do um
corporate lex
um guaranteed to landlords whatever you
do at the moment
right now oh right okay just residential
students
when you go in they're rude
and there was me thinking manchester
would be a friendly place
it says the article four is in the whole
of manchester
i still love manchester but this is
tough because yes
article four the agents hate us
we'll get there bro sorry we can't take
your call at present
please leave a message after the tone
please leave a message after the tone
it's almost like every agent is is just
not having it
i did think that would paul would be a
bit further than where we are already it
just seems like they won't even let us
in the door well
they won't even be like i couldn't have
a look around the property or exactly
if you want to if you if you want to
taste bitter rejection go and try and
find a rent to rent deal in manchester
it's a hard slug in it it really is
i thought this would be easy
and i would have thought the other way
around but i thought london would be
like this and manchester will be easy
yeah yeah
but it really isn't
just got rejected very badly
he started to cry
[Music]
good afternoon hi dear my name is lawton
hotwood what i'm looking for is
a dude in fact actually sorry do you
deal with like hmos
so what it is is basically we work with
landlords um offering them a guaranteed
rent say for over three years
unlike on a corporate
well i wasn't let we don't deal with
anything like that and
not to my knowledge anyway it's not
something that we've dealt with recently
i just gotta keep ringing come on
we've got another rent to rent person to
speak to now haven't we a rental rent
agent yeah i'm meeting yeah at 11.
feeling good um
do you do you watch with corporate
letters
so in terms of like sort of dealing with
landlords and doing like long
long term less no no
what it is i'm after i'm trying to find
like flats are great as well we mainly
look for houses
and we try and work with landlords and
on like a long term let
and we don't know if that's something
that you
you guys do with your place were you
[Music]
back to the drawing board yeah there it
is yeah
i thought he said we weren't going to
come back today until we got a rent to
rent
yeah well it all used to rent a rent
no all right okay no problem i
appreciate your time steve
cheers bye
it's depressing being told no over and
over again
so it's been hard man god
mate it's probably been the hardest one
basically um
lawton has said that if he hasn't got i
went to india by tomorrow he's just
gonna quit
so did he get any recommended deals no
so he didn't become fighters no
sweet are you going to put the footage
out or what
i don't know